hi everyone thanks for joining us for
CBN second annual virtual symposium
advances in drug discovery and
development I'm Amanda Yarnell managing
editor for editorial at CNN and I'm
delighted to introduce our next speaker
Robert plunge vice president at merck
research labs in Boston he is founder in
worldwide head of head of the department
of genetics and pharma chido max and
earlier this year launched marks new
translation medicine department roberts
talk today we'll focus on redefining
translational medicine for efficient
drug discovery I'm extorting I'm excited
to hear how human genetics can
contribute to drug discovery and
development and to learn more about the
role that biomarkers and clinical proof
of concept studies play and testing
therapeutic hypotheses are we back to
moderate a Q&A session immediately
following the presentation I welcome
your questions at any time just click
the green Q&A button in the left corner
of your screen and if you need any
technical assistance during the
presentation please click on the support
button located at the top right of your
screen and now I'll try it over to
Robert okay thank you very much again
this is a this is Robert plunge at merck
research labs and i will be speaking to
you for the next half hour on redefining
translational medicine for efficient
drug discovery so I want to start just
by defining what what I consider to be
the fundamental problem in drug
discovery and while there are many I
think you can actually be distilled into
two key issues the first has to do with
the very high failure rate of programs
in phase 2 and phase 3 drug
development so as you can see in the
slide in the figure on the left the cost
of drug discovery continues to go up and
much of the cost can be attributed not
to the successes but rather can be
attributed to the failures of drug
discovery but the second problem is a
bit more difficult to describe it's
actually around the the rising health
care costs and the demand for innovative
breakthrough therapies it's very
important that the drug discovery
industry not just deliver medicines that
work and deliver them at a lower cost
but also deliver medicines that will
drive down the cost of health care and
improve the lives of patients and I like
to think of these two problems as the
first one is the attrition problem that
is too many things fail and then the
second problem is the the innovation
problem again that is we need to create
innovative therapies that ultimately
drive down the cost of health care with
the guard should the attrition problem
this is actually change this has changed
over time so in the 1990s the failures
were due to drug metabolism and
pharmacokinetics and pharmacodynamics DM
PK and so as shown in the silver box
here about forty percent of failures
could be attributable to dmpk and in
contrast at that time about thirty
percent of failures could be attributed
to to efficacy today however this is
actually changed and now the majority of
failures are due to efficacy you can see
fit phase two failures in 2008 to 2010
over half were due to failures due to
efficacy and this number was even larger
for Phase three failures so that is
despite all of the wonderful preclinical
work that's done and
despite the phase one study is that
hopefully should establish proof of
concept many things still fail because
they just don't work in humans the
second problem is the innovation problem
and here I like to cite amazon as an
example of challenges that are similar
to lower phase in the pharmaceutical
industry so what amazon is said is we
want to be the earth's most
customer-centric company and where the
customers can find and discover
everything that they might want to buy
online and importantly at the lowest
possible prices that is not only they
want to deliver innovation they want to
deliver innovation that drives down the
cost of the retail business I think in
the pharmaceutical industry I think we
have an obligation not only two to
deliver innovative therapeutic product
but also ultimately to drive down the
cost of health care so I think many
people would actually wouldn't argue
with those two fundamental challenges of
drug discovery and development process
that the challenge of course is well how
do we fix it and what are the guiding
principles towards addressing these
fundamental challenges and what I would
like to talk about today are what I see
is is three key guiding principles and
the first has to do with the very front
end of the drug discovery process around
target ID and validation that is
deciding which targets we pursue at the
very beginning of a drug discovery
process and I'll talk about this more of
the course of the presentation but i
actually think one of the key issues
around defining which targets when
perturbed have a desired effect on him
physiology and i refer to this as causal
human biology but the second main second
main guiding principle is around
developing biomarkers that are going to
capture this human biology they're going
to capture causal human biology and
these biomarkers can measure therapeutic
modulation not in a preclinical model
that that's useful as well but
ultimately in in a human
and this is more than just target
engagement this actually has to do with
a therapeutic molecule binding to the
target and modulated in a way that
recapitulates the underlying causal
human biology the third important
guiding principle is around testing
therapeutic hypotheses in humans as
quickly and efficiently as possible in
clinical proof of concept clinical
trials and and I will differentiate
proof of biology proof of mechanism and
proof of concept in clinical trials
ultimately it's proof of concept that
determines whether a drug will be
successful and therefore approved and I
think that if we can address these
fundamental principles that ultimately
this will deliver a portfolio projects
into phase 2 and phase 3 clinical trials
that have a higher probability of
success and not just success for being
improved but also success for delivering
breakthrough therapies so another way to
think about this is about the past
versus the future I think technology is
changing the way we think about drug
discovery and develop and it is changing
the ideal model organism for drug
discovery and development so it used to
be that most of the targets were
identified in preclinical species
because they're just they're more
tractable in terms of understanding
biology and that drugs were developed
based upon these model organisms and
then taken into heterogeneous patient
populations I think what we're trying to
go and in the future is to use humans as
the ideal model organism not just for
identifying new targets but also for
precision medicine so increasingly
technology allows us to understand human
biology differentiate cause and
consequence to find those targets that
won't recur rather have the desired
effect we still and there still is a
very important role of preclinical
animal models to test aspects of
pharmacology and safety but ultimately
we want to try to translate human
observation
into precise patient populations in
small clinical trials ok I will spend
the remainder of the time going over
several examples I'll focus on human
genetics throughout as one component of
causal human biology but to say from the
outset human genetics is not the only
way to define new drug targets so just
to make sure we level set on on what the
challenge is with target identification
and how human genetics can help so in
the on the Left I'm showing you what I'm
calling I'll use this term is target I
think probably most people are familiar
with that but if you have a disease
state something to abnormal you can then
define this as a target and develop a
drug against it and then it's simpler on
this particular slide of course but that
takes a disease state into a healthy
state right this is this is what we hope
to accomplish but the challenge is shown
here on the right there are tens of
thousands of potential targets in the
human body it's really hard to know
which ones cause disease and even if you
thought you were quite convinced that
this particular target is somehow
causally related to disease process
there is also another level of
complexity which is how do you actually
perturb that target to fix the
underlying disease state so how can
human genetics help human genetics can
help identify differences germline
differences individuals that distinguish
does these individuals and that's shown
in red from healthy individuals not
showing right and if you can do this
this at least in theory should unveil
new targets which could be the starting
point of a drug discovery process and
there are several key steps to translate
human genetics into successful drug
discovery programs first is that it's
important to map genetic differences and
those with disease versus those without
disease and I say disease this could
also be a quantitative trait or some
other physiologic measurement
is relevant to drug discovery second is
to understand how these genetic
differences lead to this disease state
or this quantitative state some
physiologic measurement that you think
is important to to help them into
disease and then third is to develop
drugs against these targets that somehow
reverse this underlying pathological
process and and I want to be clear I
don't mean gene therapy necessarily
although that's one a potential way to
reverse an underlying disease process
what I actually mean is to have a drug
that actually somehow modulates the
target and reverses either that target
or that sort of underlying
pathophysiology so I'll go over just a
couple of examples I think that most
people are probably familiar with the
example of Human Genetics pcsk9 and LDL
low rate and I'll just walk you through
this example very quickly so as I'm
showing in the upper left there are many
genes which influence cholesterol levels
in the risks of heart disease in the
healthy population thanks to a number of
new technologies such as genome-wide
Association studies and next-generation
sequencing we can now identify these
genetic differences in those with
disease versus those without disease the
next challenge of course is to translate
this into an underlying kind of
biological model in the case of pcsk9
through animal model studies and other
preclinical studies both in humans and
in model organisms it was understood
that pcsk9 is involved in LDL receptor
recycling and that LDL pcsk9 can
actually bind to help internalize and
therefore degrade the LDL receptor and
loss-of-function mutations led to lower
LDL cholesterol protection from
cardiovascular disease which then
implied and generate this therapeutic
hypothesis that a monoclonal antibody
against pcsk9 would recapitulate this
biology lead to more LDL receptor on the
surfaces that of cells and therefore
more internalization of LDL cholesterol
and more clearance of LDL cholesterol
from the blood so in addition to
anecdotal examples such as pcsk9 there's
also evidence that portfolios of
projects based upon human genetics have
a higher probability of success and
against success means efficacy in phase
2 and phase 3 clinical studies this is a
nature reviews drug discovery our
article on astrazeneca's pipeline that
was published a couple of years ago and
what this actually shows is that they
see something quite similar in terms of
of phase 2 and in phase 2a and 2b many
of the failures are due to safety I and
also in efficacy and if you ask for what
factors predict success human genetics
is one aspect which actually doubles the
probability that a program will be
successful in phase to another predictor
of success is to have biomarkers and
they have biomarkers that are efficacy
biomarkers based upon M ideally causal
human biology and so these are two
important predictors of success I'm also
point you to a recent nature genetic
study by Matt Nelson and his colleagues
at GSK and they show something actually
quite similar again portfolios of prod
of programs based upon human genetics
have a higher probability of success and
what they're showing in the graph on the
right is the odds that a program will be
successful and whether that there is
genetic data from Mendelian disorders or
omen whether genetic just data from jus
us databases as well and the bottom line
here again is that genetic data predicts
successful drug discovery programs okay
so it'll be a theme here which i always
say sure human genetics is useful but
what's the strategy I'm sure we have
these problems such as attrition and
innovation but what is the strategy so
what I like to do is spend a few minutes
just talking about what is the de
génétique strategy how can we actually
think about how to use human genetics to
establish causal links and again to
identify novel growth targets so the way
I have to frame this this this problem
is to describe what happens in
development programs and ultimately a
successful drug has this dose-response
relationship where you can differentiate
an efficacy signal from a toxicity
signal and this is a therapeutic window
unfortunately in drug development this
happens after many many years and many
millions of dollars and that's the
ultimate test of success of the drug and
what we'd like to do is to try to move
this as early as possible into the drug
discovery and development process to try
to determine those response at the time
a new target is identified at the time a
drug discovery program is launched and
human genetics can help with this and
I'll just walk you through that very
quickly so on the x-axis is gene
function and on the y-axis is human
phenotype this could be a phenotype
thats related to run disease risk or a
quantitative phenotype such as high
versus low cholesterol levels and the
very first and the most important step
in this process is to pick a phenotype
that's relevant for drug Africa Z so not
all clinical phenotypes are relevant for
drug discovery I think some such as risk
of diabetes or leumit or arthritis do
have direct empirical evidence they've
been valuable for drug discovery and
other quantitative phenotypes such as
LDL cholesterol levels are also good
phenotypes others may be more difficult
the next step is then to identify
ideally not just one allele but multiple
alleles with a range of effect sizes on
the human phenotype of interest that are
correlated or associated orally
to that human in time but in this age of
this exercise we really don't know
anything about gene function so the next
step is to assess these alleles for
function characterizing gain of function
or loss of function and if you do this
you can really begin to sort of least in
theory begin to create an efficacy a
dose-response curve but human genetics
XA is a fairly unique feature and that
is plie trophy and you can ask are these
same alleles associated with other
phenotypes that may be considered
adverse drug events and it this can be
done by linking genetic data and large
bio banks that also have clinical data
for example electronic healthcare data
and so through Clea trilby you can use
this as a proxy for adverse drug events
and again this provides evidence for a
therapeutic window at the very beginning
of the drug discovery process and in
theory if we can find a surreal
experience and draw these dose-response
curves this would be a very promising
starting point for drug discovery screen
so what look frequently the question
that's frequently asked at this point in
the presentation is sure there's pcsk9
but are there any other examples or is
that really an exception and I think
there is a growing list of genes with
this allylic series and I've highlighted
a few here one of the other examples
that's prominently cited as nav 1.7 or
scn 9a as a phenotype thats related to
pain insensitivity and also increase
pain sensitivity but even if you can't
find Jean with an allylic series there's
an increasing list of genes with loss of
function protective variants and I just
highlight a few that are actually shown
here and several of these have actually
led to the development of successful
drugs such as ccr5 antagonists okay but
what to me is probably want one of the
most exciting aspects of this is that
you know as the cost of sequencing
continues to drop we are seeing a much
larger number of genomes that are being
standing much of this is in the form of
whole exome sequencing but increasingly
old genome sequencing as well and this
trend is going to continue as the cost
of genome sequencing drops so that we
will make these connections between
genetic variants and molecular
phenotypes and therefore a more accurate
molecular understanding of human disease
and on this slide I'm just highlighting
a few of these initiatives that are
linking human genetic data with clinical
phenotypes in a setting that's amenable
for recall for additional functional
studies I think many people are familiar
with with decode genetics in Iceland
there's the genomics England project to
sequence a hundred thousand individuals
the United States has launched their
precision medicine initiative where
General has partnered with with with
geisinger to create a similar biobank
and there are other examples that are
shown here and many more examples that
aren't shown here so I think you know
over the next decade many many genomes
will be sequenced many connections will
be made many genes will be identified
with this allylic serious model I said
this at the beginning I want to
emphasize this as well as that genetics
is one way to establish these causal
relationships but there are other ways
to establish relationships between
perturbations of targets and physiologic
outcomes that is cause economic biology
one example is with Auto antibodies for
example autoimmune thyroid disease and
therefore the therapy here is that word
replacement there are examples that were
purposing for example sildenafil and
erectile dysfunction if experimental
medicine studies are done correctly you
can give physiologic challenges such as
observing differences in cortisol levels
and linking back to clinical outcome in
this case rheumatoid arthritis this
could have helped establish causal
relationships and there are other ways
to do longitudinal profiling so I just
highlight some of those examples to make
sure that everyone understands that
genetics is one way that it certainly
isn't
so the bottom line here is I think
increasingly there will be these
large-scale studies in humans for
example genome sequencing that will
establish causal links between target
perturbation and physiologic outcome so
even once you actually have a target is
of course a very important step in drug
discovery and development which is to
develop a therapeutic molecule that
modulates the target in the particular
way I actually won't talk much about
that although that's a very obviously
key step in this process when I will
spend a little bit of time on is talking
about how we can actually develop
biomarkers that measure therapeutic
modulation again with an emphasis on the
human system and here I'll use the
example of base inhibitors in alzheimers
disease so just a little bit of
background on the history of drug
development in Alzheimer's disease i
think one could say in summary it's not
very pretty it is it is there are
particularly high failure rates in
Alzheimer's disease even more so than
for other complex trades and in this
study was published in Nature abused of
drug discovery earlier in the year which
highlighted the high failure rate and
Alzheimer's disease you know that's
shown this number here compared to the
industry average for other other
therapeutic areas or other indications
interest there's been as prominent
hypothesis around amyloid deposition and
risk of Alzheimer's disease and in the
case of our Merck has a base inhibitor
program visit to be very clear on that
as do other companies as well but
there's also evidence linking this
particular pathway to Alzheimer's risk
and so the causal human biology for this
particular program is actually not based
directly it's one step removed and that
is the amyloid precursor protein so the
causal human biology here has to do with
mutations in this pathway in particular
there's a mutation that reduces
Alzheimer's disease risk that is
protective and it has an effect on
decreasing a beta cleavage but they're
also naturally occurring
bodies that bind to these alpha beta
oligomers and also appear to decrease
Alzheimer's risk so there is some causal
evidence that this pathway is related to
house hunters disease so the therapeutic
hypothesis then is that base inhibition
blocks the release of toxic a bail
levels and reduces Alzheimer's disease
progression that three steps are shown
on this slide again protective a PP
mutations reduce base 1 cleavage in
vitro and that's shown here second in
the therapeutic hypothesis is that base
one inhibition will mimic this a PP Minh
and block the first step in the release
of toxic a beta peptides and that this
will then really lead to a decrease in a
data Olga MERS in the brain and
therefore protect from Alzheimer's
disease so what I want to focus on here
is not necessarily the genetic evidence
that implicates this target in this
pathway but i want to emphasize how this
can actually be linked to biomarkers to
conduct a robust clinical trial and hear
what i'm showing is that a beta peptide
levels can actually be measured directly
in the cerebral spinal fluid the CSF and
therefore serve as a biomarker not just
a target engagement at a target
modulation and so this would be a proof
of biology a proof of mechanism but not
necessarily a proof of concept is for
that you need to see improvement in
Alzheimer's disease itself so here give
the drug you measure gather CSF and you
may measure the biomarker and ask does
it drug engage and modulate the target
in the way that you think it should and
this can be done in healthy volunteers
but it can also be done in patients with
Alzheimer's disease so what I'm showing
you here is Mercs compound that lowers a
beta levels in the CSF from healthy
volunteers and that's on the left and in
addition to that and in patients with
Alzheimer's disease and that's shown on
the right so with increasing dose of the
drug you can actually see that the
levels go down
of a beta 40 levels in the CSF and I
think the important point here is that
with therapeutic modulation of base
inhibitor with this particular compound
we can get more than ninety percent
lowering of a beta levels in the CSF of
patients that are helping or individuals
who are healthy and also health summers
patients okay so this this I think
provides a good example of linking the
first two steps that is a target rooted
in human biology and a biomarker that's
based upon human biology however and
this is actually should be a uppercase H
in terms of however this is a big if the
human mutations are an appt so we're
actually one step removed away from the
college neurobiology evidence you know I
I told you I think a good story around
this relationship between CSF a beta
peptide levels and target perturbation
but we don't really know and we don't
have a for example an established
relationship that one could actually use
with Mendelian randomization between
carriers of these particular mutations
and na a beta peptide levels and
ultimately you know this is the ultimate
test of a therapeutic hypothesis and the
phase 3 clinical trials are underway and
it remains to be determined if this
therapeutic modulation will have a
beneficial effect okay to me what makes
this area very exciting there are all
sorts of new technologies that can be
used to measure human physiology this
could be next generation sequencing
there are all sorts of interesting
nanotechnology I said I increasingly we
will be able to measure target
modulation in a way that we weren't able
to do before so the bottom line is that
an important component of a successful
drug discovery program or translational
medicine program is to have robust
biomarkers to allow proof of mechanism
studies in clinical trials and there are
new technologies that are being
developed okay so in the last five
minutes I just want to quickly remind
you and go over an example of how all
three of these can be stitched together
to test a therapeutic
and patients in a relatively small study
design so here all using the example of
an approved drug that targets the
erection receptor and its allure
erection receptor antagonist in full
disclosure this is also a rogue drug
it's called Subaru xcent and it's
approved as a new therapeutic approach
to treat insomnia I will go through the
the underlying human biology in detail
but I think it's interesting to note
that the cause of human biology link
here is around not necessarily genetics
but around autoimmune or X and
efficiency in humans which results in in
narcolepsy there is also this
interesting connection between genetic
deficiency and dogs which leads to
narcolepsy and the erection pathway is
actually conserved across species so
here the therapeutic hypothesis is that
a wreck so receptor antagonism will
block the wake promoting cycle and
therefore enable sleep and that's
graphically illustrated in the four
quadrants on this slide so in the upper
left quadrant this is what a weight
signal looks like and during sleep you
can see this system it is blocked and
this correlates over time with the
active and inactive state and therefore
the therapeutic hypothesis is by
blocking orexin in this room and induce
sleep and here I think the most
important point to emphasize is that a
now a we have a clinical not just proof
of mechanism but a proof-of-concept
study in healthy volunteers to use
polysomnography to measure sleep and
what I find very interesting about this
particular example is it was done and
only 20 individuals and you can see this
relationship between dose of the drug
and either total sleep time or a sleep
efficiency index so I think these are
the types of things that we want to do
and going forward select targets based
on causal human biology develop robust
biomarkers and get into the clinic is
as possible of course as safely as
possible to test clinical proof of
concept and you can hear one of the most
exciting things to me is that they're
all sorts of new technologies that are
being developed to measure clinical
outcomes including a variety of tools
for real-time patient monitoring and I
just highlight a few here for example a
Content contact lens developed by google
that can measure glucose they're all
sorts of other mobile technologies that
can actually link a patient reported
outcomes to different interventions and
one example is a study done with
patients like me and Biogen and that's
shown on the right so here again the
bottom line is that there are new
platforms to test not just clinical
proof of mechanism the clinical proof of
concept and hopefully this will allow it
to advance novel targets into the clinic
and these technologies are continuing to
be developed and many are actually here
today so I will conclude simply by sort
of voicing really some optimism and
excitement about where we are in drug
discovery and say that we do really live
in an amazing time where there's a
confluence of events centered around
human and understanding of human biology
but for the development of new targets
through genetics and other means the
development of robust biomarkers and
also for the ability to test their
hypotheses in humans as quickly and as
safely as possible and so with that I
will I will stop and be happy to answer
any any questions
okay so Robert and one of the questions
that's come in is I do you envision a
time when all clinical trial volunteers
will have that routinely have their
genome sequence and at what price point
like that happen okay I'll repeat the
question um for Robert do you envision a
time when all clinical trial volunteers
will routinely have their genomes
sequenced and at what price point might
that happen
okay so if I I'm following this
correctly I think I can pull up a
question number 13 and the question is
do you envision a time when all clinical
trial volunteers will routinely have
their genome sequenced and at what price
point could that happen so absolutely i
mean it's hard for me to imagine the
time that this does not happen in the
future and i think internally the price
point given that big big cost of giving
the cost of exome or genome sequencing
it really is approaching you know the
cost of the basic blood test that's
somewhere in the range of five hundred
to a thousand dollars depend upon I
guess who you talk to of course the data
analysis is a is a totally different
question and that's actually continues
to be quite challenging but I think this
is just one example of how these
databases will continue to develop over
time not just as part of routine patient
care but I think as part of clinical
trials as well
okay Robert um hopefully you can hear me
now is the high failure rate for
treating Alzheimer's associated more
with the ineffectiveness of the drugs or
their inability to cross the blood-brain
barrier okay so question number 12 is is
the high failure rate for treating
Alzheimer's as the high thorac
recruiting Alzheimer's associated more
with the ineffective the drugs or their
inability to cross the blood-brain
barrier and you know i think it's i
think it's it's both I'm I think in
terms of Alzheimer's disease it's an
incredibly a complex disease process and
we don't know the relationship of causal
relationship between target perturbation
and an outcome so I think that's one
important component of the challenges
and alzheimers disease it's also a
disease that takes many many years to
develop and there's a question of when
the right time to actually intervene
some of the studies are actually being
done in base inhibitor and the basin
header trials are being done early in
early onset or i should say in patients
with mild cognitive impairment and
trying to use and I didn't touch upon
this but I should have biomarkers for
enrichment of patients that are most
likely benefit from these therapeutic
interventions and I think that you know
in the blood-brain barrier makes a
challenge to develop drugs that actually
access the right targets but there are
ways in which this
this this can be done and so I don't
think this ended up itself is the major
barrier for developing drugs and
alzheimers I really do think it's about
targets in the time course of disease
and understanding human physiology any
comments on organ on a chip technology
how would help in drug discovery okay
the next question has to do with any
comments on organ on a chip technology
and how would help drug discovery I
think there are a number of mech new
technologies such as organ on a chip
such as induced pluripotent stem cells
or ipscs I think all of these are doing
a better job of modeling the human
system so I think that they will help us
test therapeutic molecules and pathways
in a way that it wasn't possible before
so i think these technologies are very
very valuable i think we have to be very
careful about the application in terms
of identifying new targets but depending
upon the study that's actually done you
can imagine doing for example in a
phenotypic screening when you think a
readout in the northern area chip
technology or an ipscs is very valuable
to underline human disease process and
therefore it could be the starting point
of the group discovery program but but
but you know absolutely these new
technologies anything that's going to
model the human system more effectively
I think will be be very important
ok that's all
we have thanks Robert for your
fascinating presentation and thanks to
all of you for tuning in in case you
want to watch it again Robert stuff will
be archived and available on demand at
the conference website for three months
after the live broadcast until December
16 2015 Chris Austin of NIH is up next
at the top of the hour and there are a
lot more great talks to come throughout
the rest of the afternoon you can find
the full program on the agenda page
located at the upper right hand of your
side of your screen and in the meantime
please stop by the virtual exhibit hall
and the lounge where you can check out
all of our sponsors and exhibitors or
network with other attendees thanks very
much